From buzzworthy biopics to high-profile action
thrillers, Netflix is roaring into 2023.
Here are 25 of the most-anticipated films
coming our way on Netflix this year.
After finding critical success with 2020's
Extraction, director Sam Hargrave is back,
along with the Russo Brothers, with Extraction
2.
Due to hit Netflix sometime in 2023, Extraction
2 will again focus on Chris Hemsworth's Tyler
Rake, a black ops mercenary tasked with a
life-or-death mission.
"With the title of "2" behind your name, you
have to bring at least twice the action."
Extraction was a refreshing entry in the action
genre, and Hemsworth delivered a career-defining
performance, for which he received praise
from audiences and critics alike.
The film became one of Netflix's most-watched
originals ever, reaching 99 million households
in its first month on the streaming service.
"You drown not by falling into the river,
but by staying submerged in it."
Besides Hemsworth, a definitive cast list
hasn't been made public, though Golshifteh
Farahani is set to reprise her role of Nik
Khan, Tyler's partner.
No release date has been pinned down, but
filming is said to have wrapped last April.
It's been 23 years since Peter Lord and Nick
Park created Chicken Run, a triumphant piece
of stop-motion animation.
Chicken Run remains the highest-grossing stop-motion
film ever, raking in over $227 million at
the box office.
Chicken Run: Dawn of the Nugget was greenlit
in 2018 by StudioCanal, and Netflix acquired
the rights in 2020.
The film will focus on Ginger and her friends
after they escape Tweedy's farm.
"Is it as good as you imagined?"
"No."
"No?"
"It's better."
Jane Horrocks, Imelda Staunton, and Lynn Ferguson
are the only original actors to reprise their
roles from the first movie.
But given the critical response to the first
film, we should expect another brilliant,
entertaining story from Lord and Park.
Adaptations of books by renowned children's
author Roald Dahl have often become movie classics.
Beginning with 1971's Willy Wonka & the Chocolate
Factory all the way to Roald Dahl's The Witches
" in 2020, Dahl's work has been a linchpin
in cinema for five decades.
In 2021, Netflix acquired the rights to the
Roald Dahl Story Company, paying over $680
million dollars for the author's bibliography.
First up is The Wonderful Story of Henry Sugar,
helmed by acclaimed director Wes Anderson.
Published in 1977, The Wonderful Story of
Henry Sugar follows Sugar, a gambler who dares
to use meditation to count cards.
Anderson's adaptation will explore the destruction
of greed that Dahl's adult-skewed fairy tale examined.
With Benedict Cumberbatch set to play Sugar,
and a supporting cast of Ralph Fiennes, Dev
Patel, and Ben Kingsley, The Wonderful Story
of Henry Sugar should be a marvelous entry
in the Dahl cinematic universe.
Though it hit theaters for a limited release
on December 23, Scott Cooper's The Pale Blue
Eye was the first original movie to stream
on Netflix in 2023.
Netflix seems to be starting the year off
with a lot of corpses and conspiracies.
The Pale Blue Eye doesn't skimp on brutality,
which adds another layer of darkness to Cooper's
period piece.
"It is a whodunnit."
"It's a fictional story about a series of
murders that take place at West Point."
Set in 1830, The Pale Blue Eye follows Augustus
Landor, played by Christian Bale, as he investigates
murders within the U.S. military, alongside
a young Edgar Allan Poe, played by Harry Melling.
"With enough patience, a suspect will often
interrogate himself."
The movie is based on Louis Bayard's 2003
novel of the same name and has a terrific
cast that includes Gillian Anderson and Robert
Duvall among many other standouts.
Fans of the Beverly Hills Cop franchise have
been waiting 28 years for another installment
and, in 2023, their time will finally come.
Beverly Hills Cop: Axel Foley marks another
turn in Murphy's ongoing career renaissance.
Hoping to capitalize on the acclaim he received
for his performances in Dolemite Is My Name
and Coming 2 America, audiences can only hope
that the comedian can slip back into the persona
of his most beloved character.
"Yes, you have a reservation for an Axel Foley."
The story follows Axel as he comes back to
Beverly Hills to sniff out corruption in his
old police department.
"Can you put this in a good spot?
All this s— happened the last time I parked
here."
Many of the franchise's original cast, including
Judge Reinhold and Bronson Pinchot, are set
to return, while Taylour Paige, Kevin Bacon,
and Joseph Gordon-Levitt will take on brand
new characters.
Beverly Hills Cop has a storied legacy, with
the original film consistently labeled as
one of the funniest movies ever made, so Beverly
Hills Cop: Axel Foley has a lot to live up to.
It'll be exciting to see the old gang back
in action for the first time in almost 30 years.
Not much is known about the film adaptation
of Matt Kindt's comic book series Dept.
H, though it's set to hit Netflix sometime
this year.
Alice Waddington is slated to direct the film,
her first credit since her feature debut,
Paradise Hills, in 2019.
Dept. H revolves around Mia, a special investigator
hired to derail a saboteur's plan at a deep
sea research facility.
The series traverses a long, complicated crime
scene that plays out like a nautical game
of Clue, where suspects must prove their innocence
while surviving against the creatures surrounding them.
How Waddington will condense Kindt's work
into one feature film will be something worth
keeping note of.
No cast list has yet been released.
Kindt's series ran for almost two full years.
Given that the comic doesn't have the biggest
fanbase, that leaves the door wide open for
Waddington to make the source material her
own.
It's one of the most-anticipated Netflix releases
and comic book adaptations of 2023.
In one of Netflix's most high-profile releases
of 2023, Tom Harper's Heart of Stone has garnered
a lot of attention thanks to its illustrious
cast, which includes Gal Gadot and Jamie Dornan
in the leading roles.
Heart of Stone will be Harper's first directorial
effort since The Aeronauts in 2019.
The story revolves around Rachel Stone, a
CIA agent navigating altercations with dangerous
global powers.
"Rachel Stone lives off the adrenaline.
She's addicted to it."
Most of the plot is being kept under wraps.
We just know that it's a spy action thriller.
Sophie Okonedo, Matthias Schweighöfer, Jing
Lusi, and Alia Bhatt are set to play supporting roles.
Written, directed, and starring Jerry Seinfeld,
Unfrosted: The Pop-Tart Story is one of Netflix's
most anticipated comedies of the upcoming
year.
Seinfeld has directed before, including episodes
of his own show, Comedians in Cars Getting
Coffee, and two of Colin Quinn's stand-up
specials.
Netflix won the rights to the film in 2021,
the premise of which stems from Seinfeld's
own joke about the Pop-Tart's inception.
"They can't go stale, 'cause they were never
fresh."
In the story, two breakfast cereal titans,
Kellogg's and Post, duke it out, competing
to make the first ever mass-produced breakfast
pastry in the Vietnam War-era Midwest.
Unfrosted has an Olympic-level cast signed
on already, including Melissa McCarthy, Amy
Schumer, and Bobby Moynihan, to name just
a few.
"It's like 15 stand-up comics are in this."
What will come of a film brimming with some
of the 21st century's greatest comedians?
"You know, in my world, the wronger something
feels, the righter it is."
In what will be his second release through
Netflix within a year, Jonah Hill has teamed
up with black-ish creator Kenya Barris to
make You People.
Hill and Barris co-wrote the script together.
The film examines the intersection of culture
disparities with modern love plus a sprinkling
of generational issues added to the mix, as
Hill and Lauren London play an interracial
couple meeting each others' families for the
first time.
"So do you hang out in the hood all the time
or do you just come up here for our food and women?"
As Hill and London's in-laws-to-be are Eddie
Murphy, Nia Long, Julia Louis-Dreyfus, and
David Duchovny.
Considering Barris's success with black-ish
and Hill's ability to perfectly blend comedy
and drama, You People is shaping up to be
one of the most intriguing releases of 2023.
Netflix's catalog in 2023 won't be short of
action films, though Havoc might end up being
one of the streamer's best of the year.
Directed by Gareth Evans, who last helmed
Apostle in 2018, Havoc will mark the first
non-Venom performance by Tom Hardy since Capone
in 2020.
Havoc focuses on the aftermath of a bad drug
deal, when Hardy's detective character, Walker,
must survive within the dark underbelly of
crime in his city.
Walker is tasked with saving the kidnapped
son of a high-ranking politician while watching
his home unravel from the vices of greed and
corruption.
As with many of Netflix's upcoming releases,
Havoc has a promising cast, highlighted by
Forest Whitaker, Timothy Olyphant, Justin
Cornwell, and Jessie Mei Li.
Evans is a relatively unproven director, but
this film could completely change all that.
Hardy is an exemplary leading man, so Havoc
shouldn't have any trouble finding its audience,
especially viewers who are fans of Netflix's
blockbuster action flick, Extraction.
Director Rawson Marshall Thurber has been
tapped to helm Netflix's new dystopian thriller
The Division.
It's his first credit since Red Notice in
2021, although he's perhaps best known for
directing the comedies Dodgeball: A True Underdog
Story and We're the Millers.
The Division details how a futuristic, fast-spreading
virus is being contracted through people handling
paper money.
The events reach an apex on Black Friday,
the biggest shopping day of the year, in New York City.
What unfolds is the dissolution of society
amid a great viral catastrophe, in which the
fate of the country rests in the hands of
civilians who must fight against bio-terrorists
while the government races to find a cure.
As of right now, the only cast members confirmed
are Jessica Chastain and Jake Gyllenhaal.
Chastain and Gyllenhaal are two of the most
reliable leading actors working in Hollywood
right now, so The Division should be a thrilling
story to watch.
Step Up: All In and Pitch Perfect 3 director
Trish Sie's next film is the romantic comedy
Players, due to hit Netflix in late 2023.
Netflix hasn't let too many cats out of the
bag about Players.
All we know is that it is a rom-com with a
sports fan slant.
A sportswriter, Mack, after years of flings
and hook-ups, meets a woman who inspires him
to settle down and go all in on a relationship.
Tom Ellis and Jane the Virgin star Gina Rodriguez
are slated to play the movie's leads, while
Damon Wayans Jr., Brock O'Hurn, and Joel Courtney
will take on supporting roles.
The last time we saw Ellis was in his leading
role on Lucifer, while Rodriguez was in the
Amazon Prime hit rom-com I Want You Back in
2022.
The chemistry between Ellis and Rodriguez
will be one to look out for, as they are known
for working within different genres.
Netflix is hit or miss with rom-coms these
days, but Players has a lot of potential.
High in the Clouds is easily Netflix's most
unique impending release.
An animated feature based on a children's
novel co-written by Philip Ardagh, Geoff Dunbar,
and Paul McCartney in 2005, Netflix will release
it in collaboration with Gaumont sometime
this year.
The book's illustrator, Geoff Dunbar, worked
with McCartney on the 1984 animated movie
Rupert and the Frog Song.
High in the Clouds focuses on Woodland, an
animal home about to be demolished by humans.
Wirral, a squirrel, is left orphaned by the
destruction and goes on an adventure to find
a new place to live.
His destination is Animalia, a sanctuary for
animals.
Surprisingly adult, the book tackles themes
of war, loss, and companionship, and the movie
adaptation should do the same.
The adaptation has been in development off-and-on
since 2013, with a number of filmmakers in
the mix to direct.
Officially, Head over Heels creator Timothy
Reckart will helm the film, with a script
written by Jon Croker.
McCartney will compose songs and an original
score while also executive producing.
Beatles fans and animation buffs alike are
sure to adore this film, another addition
to the still-growing legacy of McCartney,
one of the world's greatest rock stars.
In another comic book adaptation for Netflix,
Jim Mickle, co-creator of the streaming titan's
show Sweet Tooth, will direct his own rendition
of Donny Cates' God Country.
Legendary Pictures is attached to the film,
which marks another collaboration with Netflix,
after the hit films Enola Holmes and Enola
Holmes 2 released in 2020 and 2022, respectively.
"I am a detective.
I'm a decipherer.
And I'm a finder of lost souls."
God Country follows Emmett Quinlan, a widower
battling dementia.
Emmett struggles with confusion, which often
leads to violent outbursts that get him in
trouble with local police and estrange him
from his family.
After a tornado destroys his home in West
Texas, Emmett is thought to be lost, and possibly
dead, in the debris.
Instead, the disaster renders him cured and
an enchanted sword he found in the eye of
the storm gives him superhuman strength.
Far from the worlds of DC and Marvel, God
Country aims to be a refreshing entry in the
superhero genre.
“No capes!”
No cast list or plot for the film have yet
been released, but Netflix aims to deliver
it to audiences by the end of 2023.
Based on the BBC psychological thriller of
the same name, Netflix will be releasing a
film adaptation of Luther in March.
Written by series creator Neil Cross and directed
by Jamie Payne, Luther will, as star Idris
Elba noted in a conversation with Empire,
"peel the onion back" on the character of
Luther and broaden the scope beyond just the
"gritty streets of London."
"If you take me down, I'll take you down even
faster and even harder."
Luther enters an elite company of television
shows turned into movies, joining Charlie's
Angels, The X-Files, and Star Trek, among
countless others.
Elba will reprise the title role of Luther,
a police detective who has to balance the
horrors of his job with the genius of his
procedural methods.
Andy Serkis and Cynthia Erivo are set for
supporting roles.
Over the course of five seasons, Luther was
well-received by audiences and critics alike.
A BBC fan-favorite, Luther should make for
a solid film adaptation, especially with the
show's creator in charge of shaping the plot.
Directed by George C. Wolfe, the sharp eye
behind 2020's Ma Rainey's Black Bottom, Rustin
is a dramatized biopic focused on the life
of gay civil rights activist Bayard Rustin.
Screenwriter Dustin Lance Black, who won the
2009 Oscar for best original screenplay for
his Milk script, is on board to write, and
Barack and Michelle Obama's company Higher
Ground will oversee production.
Rustin is set to place a big emphasis on Rustin's
organization of the 1963 March on Washington.
Colman Domingo, who previously worked with
Wolfe in Ma Rainey's Black Bottom, is set
to play Rustin.
How Rustin will stack up against the seemingly
never-ending list of biopics remains to be
seen, but after his success with Ma Rainey,
Wolfe appears to be the perfect man to tell
the late activist's story.
Produced by Todd Phillips, Martin Scorsese,
and Steven Spielberg, Hollywood star Bradley
Cooper will direct Maestro, a biopic about
composer and humanitarian Leonard Bernstein.
Cooper co-wrote the movie with Josh Singer,
who won an Oscar for best original screenplay
in 2015 for his Spotlight script.
"Leave something for the rest of us, Bradley
Cooper."
In addition to directing, Cooper will play
Bernstein, with the film set to focus on the
composer's life, especially his marriage to
Felicia Montealegre, an actress who later
became an anti-war advocate during the Vietnam
War.
Carey Mulligan will take on the role of Montealegre.
A terrific supporting cast is already in place,
with Jeremy Strong, Matt Bomer, Maya Hawke,
and Sarah Silverman set to appear.
Cooper's choice to use a prosthetic nose in
his portrayal of Bernstein has been met with
a great deal of criticism.
Canadian Jewish News reporter James Hirsh
proclaimed that Cooper should not be playing
Bernstein at all if he is unable to do so
without the fake nose, a practical effect
that plays negatively into cultural caricatures
of Jewish people.
Maestro will certainly generate buzz come
awards season, but not without its controversies
being held up to the light first.
After helming the BBC film Marvellous, Julian
Farino is returning to the director's chair
for Our Man from Jersey.
Mark Wahlberg is set to star, coming off his
performance in Father Stu in 2022.
The last time we saw Wahlberg's co-star Halle
Berry was in the 2022 box office disaster Moonfall.
"You are the unidentified source?"
"Oh, yes."
Our Man from Jersey tells the story of a blue-collar
man becoming a hero overnight.
Wahlberg's character, Mike, is a construction
worker, at least until his high school girlfriend
Roxanne, played by Berry, convinces him to
become a spy.
Mike is a nice guy who doesn't have any interest
in turning to the world of espionage, but
it's not long before a do-or-die mission leaves
him with no choice.
J.K. Simmons, Jackie Earle Haley, Jessica De Gouw,
Adewale Akinnuoye-Agbaje, and Alice Lee round
out the cast, but few other details have been
released by Netflix so far.
Not much is known about Reptile yet, other
than the fact that Grant Singer is slated
to direct and the cast is full of names audiences
likely wouldn't expect to see come together
in the same movie.
Reptile marks Singer's feature film debut,
though he's spent the last nine years directing
music videos for Sam Smith, The Weeknd, Ariana
Grande, and Troye Sivan.
Reptile revolves around a man named Nichols,
played by Benicio Del Toro, who is a New England
detective working a mysterious case that quickly
bleeds into his own personal life.
The lines for Nichols are blurred, as he often
can't tell what's real and what's not, which
leads him down a dark path.
The cast is brimming with big names, including
Frances Fisher, Alicia Silverstone, Justin
Timberlake, Eric Bogosian, Sky Ferreira, and
Michael Pitt.
Reptile will mark a reunion between Silverstone
and Del Toro, who played each other's love
interest in Excess Baggage in 1997.
The Spy Kids franchise is one of the most
successful live-action kids movie series of
all-time, grossing over $550 million worldwide
over the course of four films.
Spy Kids has remained dormant for 12 years,
ever since creator Robert Rodriguez aimed
to shift the story's focus away from Carmen
and Juni Cortez, the stars of the first three films.
"Thumb Thumbs and fooglies coming up the south
hall."
Spy Kids: Armageddon is meant to be a total
reboot of the series, and Rodriguez has written
the script and will be serving as director.
The film will focus on how children are unintentionally
helping a game developer take over the world
through a destructive computer virus, and
must then take matters into their own hands
in order to save their families.
The cast is lead by Gina Rodriguez and Zachary
Levi, while Everly Carganilla, Connor Esterson,
Billy Magnussen, and D.J.
Cotrona round out the ensemble.
Don't go into Spy Kids: Armageddon expecting
it to be the Citizen Kane of kids espionage movies.
It probably won't dazzle critics, but it'll
be an action-packed adventure for families
on movie night.
Society of the Snow is set to be one of the
most dynamic films of 2023.
The only Spanish language entry on the list,
Society of the Snow is an adaptation of Pablo
Vierci's book The Snow Society: The Definitive
Account of the World's Greatest Survival Story,
which details the experiences of the 16 survivors
from the Andes flight disaster in 1972.
Vierci's book is particularly emotional, as
the author knew many of the survivors as a
child and felt a particular connection to
them.
J.A. Bayona will translate Vierci's story and documentation
onto the screen.
The story of the Andes flight disaster is
legendary for how unfathomable the chances
were that anyone could withstand the mountain
range's treacherous conditions for 72 days,
as well as the fact that the survivors were
forced to resort to cannibalism or starve.
"As our friends were dying, they made us realize
that we had an opportunity that they didn't.
That we had a responsibility to live for them."
The cast comprises mostly newcomers who don't
have any credits to their name, but interestingly,
Carlos Páez, one of the real-life survivors
of the flight and the youngest passenger on
the plane, will play his own father in the
film.
Directed by MCU alums Anthony and Joe Russo,
The Electric State is an adaptation of Simon
Stålenhag graphic novel.
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely, the
brains behind the Chronicles of Narnia and
Captain America franchises, penned the script,
while horror filmmakers Andy and Barbara Muschietti
are slated to produce.
Not many details about the film have been
announced, beyond the prolific ensemble cast,
but the premise is said to focus on Michelle,
a young girl who looks for her missing and
estranged brother, who has sent her a robot
from some great, unknown place.
The Electric State will be half-live-action
and half-animated.
Frequent Netflix collaborator Millie Bobby
Brown is set to play the lead role of Michelle,
while Chris Pratt, Stanley Tucci, Jason Alexander,
Brian Cox, Giancarlo Esposito, and Anthony
Mackie are among the names rounding out the
cast.
Be on the lookout for Ke Huy Quan, who is
fresh off his brilliant return to acting in
Everything Everywhere All at Once, which has
made him the best supporting actor favorite
at the 2023 Academy Awards.
After ceasing production on his hit series
Mindhunter to create the blockbuster biopic
Mank in 2020, David Fincher has returned to
Netflix to direct The Killer, an adaptation
of Alexis Nolent's graphic novel series of
the same name.
Fincher has been attached to Nolent's book
since as early as 2007, the project bouncing
from various production companies before landing
at Netflix's feet.
Only Michael Fassbender and Tilda Swinton
have been announced as principal cast members.
Audiences last saw Fassbender in 2019, when
he played Magneto in X-Men: Dark Phoenix.
Swinton had a busy 2022, as she performed
in Three Thousand Years of Longing and The
Eternal Daughter, as well as voicing the role
of the Wood Sprite in Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio.
"To save you, he became a real boy, and real
boys don't come back."
Nolent's series tells the story of a nameless
assassin who makes calculated decisions quietly.
Later revealed to be named Christian, he doesn't
have many goals, except for making enough
money to retire and leave the public eye completely.
Nolent's work is meant to test the limits
in which audiences can feel empathy for a
bad person.
If any director is capable of making that
premise work on the big screen, it's Fincher,
who found great success with dark, brutal
dramas, including Fight Club, Zodiac, and
Gone Girl.
Audiences haven't seen Anthony Stacchi in
the director's chair since 2014, when he co-directed
The Boxtrolls with Graham Annable.
"First things first.
Off with the box."
"Ahhhh!"
Known mostly for his work behind the camera,
Stacchi has built a long, storied career as
a storyboard artist and visual effects creator.
He got his start on Back to the Future in
1985, and has since worked on projects as
varied as Hook, James and the Giant Peach,
Antz, and Ghost.
The Monkey King focuses on the titular Monkey
King, who must travel near and far to get
his staff back from the wretched Dragon King.
Screenwriter Steven Benchich, who wrote Brother
Bear, Chicken Little, and Open Season, penned
the script, his first since Cats & Dogs: The
Revenge of Kitty Galore in 2010.
The Monkey King marks Benchich and Stacchi's
first collaboration since 2006.
A great cast is already in place, featuring
BD Wong, Jimmy O. Yang, and Bowen Yang, and
Stephanie Hsu.
The Monkey King will mark the first performance
for Hsu after Everything Everywhere All at
Once, which is putting her in the conversation
for best supporting actress at the Academy
Awards, as per Variety.
Matt Charman is back for his first feature
film since 2015, when he co-wrote the script
for Steven Spielberg's Bridge of Spies with
the Coen Brothers.
Charman secured an Oscar nomination for best
original screenplay, but has been awfully
quiet since.
Charman's new movie, The Mothership, follows
a single mother, Sara, played by Halle Berry,
and her kids, who stumble upon an extraterrestrial
on their property.
Sara's husband disappeared without a trace
a year earlier, and she believes her new discovery
will help bring him, or the truth of his whereabouts,
home.
This marks Berry's second collaboration with
Netflix in 2023, along with Our Man from Jersey,
in which she stars alongside Mark Wahlberg.
Molly Parker, Omari Hardwick, and Sydney Lemmon
are among the names that will round out the cast.
Parker is set to have a strong 2023, as she
will also play Mary Darling in Disney's Peter
Pan & Wendy.
Hardwick was last seen in the TV series Pieces
of Her, while Lemmon appeared in Tàr, alongside
Cate Blanchett.
A release date hasn't been set yet, but expect
The Mothership to arrive sometime in late 2023.